mayor Garcetti or should I say King
Garcetti ruler guy said I don't know
dictator cart said he came out and they
said hey fireworks in LA not gonna
happen
most violations of California fireworks
laws or misdemeanors penalties can
include up to one year in jail county
jail and/or a fine up to $1,000 but
possession of large quantities of
dangerous fireworks can be charged as
California felony punishment for felony
fireworks violation can include up to
three years in California state prison
and fines as high as you ready for this
fifty thousand dollar fine can you pull
up the video of the fireworks in LA I
think everybody's got to see this year
did you see the fireworks in LA what it
was like I said them I couldn't believe
the fireworks in LA so when this took
place let's see uh is that recent yeah
this is recent watch what happens this
is LA our city says don't do it what
it's LA do hey mayor Garcetti here's
what la told you LA told you mayor
Garcetti we don't listen to you we live
in America you ain't no president
this ain't no Europe ran by socialistic
country where a dictator can tell their
people what to do the folks in LA told
you they pretty much gave you the middle
finger to tell you we love America we're
gonna celebrate fourth of July whether
you find us or not and if you're gonna
find us
you gotta come find thousands of us
right and when I saw this video I said
let me tell you something man I love
this year the pride of LA this is where
I grew up but this is my stomping ground
this is 24 years in this year it's right
there I mean the lights are too dark for
me to be able to see the angles there
but that's a that's a lot of fire that's
a lot of fireworks man you know easiness
for cops to catch that didn't even try
to go and say let's do something about
this you're not finding people in LA
$50,000 mayor Garcetti you officially do
not have a voice in LA how does it feel
I'm curious you officially do not have a
voice in LA people no longer listen to
your voice it's a pretty
that place to me when you run a city and
people tell you we ain't listening to
you what do you think about this job
that you can spend three years in prison
for this you got up to three years so
proud of the people in LA man let me
tell you this is so impressive for me
but they're letting sexual-assault like
you know they're they're letting
perverts and all these people these peas
these professors they're letting them
out of jail but then you're gonna send
you to jail for having fireworks for
three years twenty four years I lived in
California my friends are sending me
more messages today about how furious
they are with California right now many
for many different levels right we're
getting ready to go through a transition
in our lives right now okay it's a
pretty big transition in my life that
we're going through and as we're going
through this I didn't know if I was
gonna stay in Dallas Texas the list that
I put out there you guys know the four
states and places that we talked about
when is LA and it was either gonna be
Malibu there's gonna be Newport couple
places we looked at in that area right
maybe we're looking at you know a Gore
Hills area in that kind of a area that's
a very nice area we look there we looked
at Florida Fort Lauderdale Miami Boca
area we looked at Dallas and we looked
at Greenwich the way California and LA
handle the pandemic I cannot tell you
how quickly we crossed off California I
was so looking forward to living in
California the last four months to
California from first place to fourth
place are they off the list they're
fully off the list right
you
[Music]